Started this tournament with 12
smiths from around the country.
We've ended with Ben's pick
from Clay Spencer
Blacksmith Shop
and Dave's pick
from the New Agrarian School
in Montana.
Guys, you've both proven
yourselves to be worthy smiths,
and you've earned your spot
in this final round
of the competition.
You guys are not only fighting
for $20,000
to go into your pocket,
but up to $10,000
in gear and supplies to go
back to the forge
where we met you at.
In this final round,
we're sending you back home
for four days to build
a menacing blade
from history.
We want you to build this...
the Moplah sword.
Whoa.
[Grady] The Moplah sword
traces its origins back
to 17th-century South India
where it has been
the weapon of choice
for the Moplah community,
featuring a broad,
lightweight blade
and a concave edge that flares
to a pronounced point,
making it an extremely lethal
battle sword
capable of delivering
deadly slashes
and destructive blows
upon its enemies.
While it's distinguished by
its ornate wood or bone handle,
this brutal blade
also played an important role
in the Moplah Rebellion
of the early 20th century
where it was used
to take up arms
against occupying
British colonists.
Gentlemen, good luck.
We will see you both
in four days.
[Jason] I'm going to try
to separate
my blade from Silas's blade
and do San Mai Damascus.
So I'm going to make
two billets of Damascus.
Fire in the hole.
I'm going to sandwich
the two billets of Damascus
with a piece of 80CrV.
I've made lots of Damascus,
but nothing this big.
So, drawing it out
and making it real wide,
that's gonna be a task.
I'm at three inches.
I need another inch and a half.
I don't know if I got enough.
Yeah, they're makin' me earn
this 20,000.
I don't have enough meat
to spread out,
so I gotta do the unthinkable
and just weld up
a bunch of stuff on the spine
to meet parameters.
It's about my only option
right now.
And that weld is ugly,
but it's gonna be what
it's gonna be at this point.
Yesterday, I got
the blade quenched.
[laughs]
Also, I have
all my parts made.
I just gotta put it all
together.
[groans]
This is the last step
in a very long
and difficult competition.
I've put my entire heart
and soul
into this whole project,
and if this don't make it,
then I get nothing.
I think, overall,
the blade will make Ben
and the Clay Spencer
Blacksmith Shop proud.
[Silas] The plan
for today is to get
my Damascus billet
forged out.
That's the goodness right there.
I don't really make Damascus,
and I have never made
something like this before.
Yesterday, I got my blade
all forged out and hardened.
Looks good.
I just gave it a little flex,
and a crack opened right up.
You can see the crack right
there in the edge of the blade.
And the crack goes past
where I could grind back
to meet parameters,
so, looks like
I'm startin' over.
Got some 5160,
I'm gonna forge a new blade.
Yesterday, I got my blade
quenched and ground,
and ready to put it
all together.
Okay, I think it's...
this is it.
I feel pretty good
about my progress.
I had a pretty major setback,
but I gotta rush at this point
to finish my handle.
Hopefully, I can bring home
the win
to Jeffrey
from the New Agrarian School.
Hwah!
Bladesmiths, welcome
to our dynamic KEAL test,
the ballistics dummy
and sheets of ice chop.
-Jason, you're up first. Ready?
-Yes, sir.
[exhales]
[rock music playing]
[music fading]
[suspenseful music playing]
[Doug] All right, Jason, let's
talk about your Moplah sword.
In hitting the ice blocks,
no damage on your tip
and edge.
It stayed true.
In chopping
into the ballistics dummy,
very deep, deep cuts.
And overall, your weapon,
it'll KEAL.
Thank you, sir.
-All right, Silas. You ready?
-Yes, sir.
[hard rock music playing]
[ice block clattering]
[music stops]
Good job. [chuckling]
[suspenseful music playing]
[Doug] All right, Silas, let's
talk about your Moplah sword.
First up,
this thing is light.
I could use velocity
to cut cleanly
on the ice blocks,
and those are one
of the deepest cuts
we have on a ballistics dummy,
but in the test,
you have two spots here
where I can get
my fingernail into that,
but that's because you have
a very, very acute
and sharp edge here,
and it will KEAL.
[dramatic music playing]
[chuckling]
All right, gentlemen, welcome
to our dynamic strength test,
the chain mail and skull chop.
Jason, you're up first.
You ready?
-Yes, sir.
-Okay.
[dramatic music playing]
[whacking]
[whacking and clattering]
[rock music playing]
[grunting]
[grunting and clattering]
-[grunting]
-[music stops]
[tense music playing]
All right, Jason.
This thing's a beast.
Everything's still right
and tight.
I really like what you did here.
This is really
just beautiful work.
It's a great-looking weapon,
it did the job, and it held up.
-So, nicely done.
-Thank you.
Silas, you ready?
Let's do this.
I'm going to.
[laughter]
[tense music playing]
[exhales]
[grunting and whacking]
[rock music playing]
[grunting]
Good job.
[suspenseful music playing]
[Dave] All right, Silas,
your handle,
issue I have with it
is that the handle is rounded
in a way that it wants
to turn in my hand
when I impact things.
I couldn't maintain a grip.
That's a big issue.
Thank you.
[dramatic music playing]
Gentlemen, it's been
a wild ride, guys.
I've been honored to travel
across America with these guys,
visiting all four
of the forges we went to,
watching you two work
the entire time
through this competition.
I can guarantee
that both Jeffrey and Belz
would be extremely proud
of your work.
But unfortunately, only one
of you guys can take home
the $20,000 for yourself,
the $10,000 to go back
into the forge
you're representing,
and the title
of Forged in Fire champion.
The judges did make a decision,
and today's
Forged in Fire champion
and the winner of
the On the Road tournament is...
[music intensifying]
Jason. Very well done.
Now, Silas, you crushed it
throughout the competition,
but unfortunately, your time
in this tournament has ended.
I'm gonna have to ask you
to step off the Forge floor.
[Silas] I feel disappointed.
I certainly made some mistakes
during my home forge,
and in a close competition,
mistakes are what matter,
but I'm still really proud
of representing
the New Agrarian School.
I wish that I had been able
to bring it home for them,
but that's competition.
[Grady] Jason, congratulations.
You are now
a Forged in Fire champion.
You came out on top
of this On the Road tournament,
and you're getting a check
not only for $20,000
going in your pocket,
but you're bringing back $10,000
for gear and supplies
to go back to Belz
and the Clay Spencer
Blacksmith Shop.
-Very, very well done.
-[applause]
[Jason]
I'm a Forged in Fire champion,
and I'm in shock
and awe disbelief.
It's been an honor
and a privilege to go this far,
to be the winner,
and to be bringing
$10,000 in equipment
and gear for John C. Campbell,
and my wife will be happy.
I'm comin' home
with 20 grand, hon.
[laughs]
[rock music playing]